ihr kennt der die und das als die drei
deutschen artikel der man die jacke das
handy tatsächlich sind der die und das
aber mehr als nur artikel die im
deutschen vor den namen stehen
vor kurzem hat uns unser podcast
zuhörers folgende frage geschrieben
hallo ich heiße sex und ich habe eine
grammatik frage
er sagt oft der und die wenig er oder
sie erwarte zum beispiel sagte carey wir
haben einen kommentar von set bekommen
der sagte dass und so weiter tatsächlich
ist es so dass der die und das nicht nur
artikel sind und in diesem video werden
wir euch erklären welche weiteren
funktionen
diese drei wörter haben los geht's
[Musik]
tatsächlich haben der die und das drei
funktionen der die und das sind artikel
der man die jacke das handy der die und
das sind auch relativ pronomen der mann
der über die straße geht winkt und der
die und das können auch demonstrativ
pronomen sein
janosch woher hast du denn den habe ich
geliehen artikel kennt ihr bereits sie
stehen immer vor einem nomen und
tatsächlich müsst ihr die nomen im
deutschen immer mit den dazugehörigen
artikeln lernen
der mann das haus die jacke wir haben
schon ein video darüber gemacht mit den
wichtigsten gender regeln im deutschen
und in unserer erzielen gibt es auch
einen gender trainer mit der ihr diese
artikel
mit ein bisschen mehr spaß und auch ein
bisschen systematisch lernen könnte
beide links findet ihr hier unten in der
infobox
der mann der über die straße geht winkt
in diesem satz sehen wir zwei
der das erste der ist ein artikel
das steht vor dem nomen der mann das
zweite der steht jedoch ganz alleine im
satz der über die straße geht und dieses
zweite der das ist ein so genanntes
relativ pronomen was bedeutet dass ein
pronomen steht immer an stelle eines
namens pronomen für ein omen und ein
relativ pronomen hat immer eine
beziehung zu einem anderen namen in
einem satz
das kann man sich gut merken denn dieses
relativ relatio relation relation gibt
es in ganz vielen sprachen uns bedeutet
immer beziehung wenn wir uns jetzt
diesen satz noch mal angucken
der mann der über die straße geht dann
können wir sagen dass das zweite dr
eine beziehung zu dem nomen hat der mann
der über die straße geht
der mann der über die straße geht winkt
wichtig es noch zu wissen dass ein
relativ pronomen auch in einem anderen
fall stehen kann als das nomen auf dass
es sich bezieht
und das liegt daran dass der fall immer
von dem werk oder auch manchmal von der
präposition im nebensatz abhängig ist
hier ist ein beispiel der kaffee die
nicht gekauft habe schmeckt nicht
der kaffee den ich gekauft habe
das den bezieht sich auf der kaffee aber
weil kaufen einen akkusativ braucht den
ich gekauft habe
steht das den im akkusativ während der
kaffee im domina tief steht zuletzt
schauen wir uns demonstrativ pronomen an
demonstrativ pronomen zeigen immer etwas
bestimmtes oder betonen etwas bestimmtes
bekannte demonstrativ konomen sind
dieser diese
dieses diese kaffee schmeckt nicht wenn
janisch sagt dieser kaffee schmeckt
nicht dann meint er damit diesen
bestimmten kaffee also generell
schmeckten kaffee ganz gut aber dieser
eine kaffee der schmeckt nicht
aber auch der die und das kann man als
demonstrativ pronomen einsetzen
hier ein beispiel der schmeckt nicht
in diesem satz haben wir gesehen wie die
amish der als demonstrativ pronomen
benutzt
der kaffee schmeckt nicht und wenn man
der die und das im deutschen als
demonstrativ pronomen benutzt dann ist
das tatsächlich etwas was für viele
leute die deutsch lernen überraschend
ist denn manchmal kann das im englischen
auch mit biss oder web übersetzt werden
manchmal werden diese demonstrativ
pronomen jedoch auch einfach mit einem
personalpronomen im englisch übersetzt
zum beispiel he she
oder ist hier ist noch ein beispiel
woher hast du denn den habe ich geliehen
in diesem beispiel habe ich gefragt
woher hast du dem und johannes hat
geantwortet den habe ich geliehen
im englischen würde man hier
wahrscheinlich nicht mit einem
demonstrativ pronomen übersetzen sondern
einfach sagen rente tipp wenn ihr jetzt
noch andere grammatik fragen habt dann
schreibt uns doch gerne einen kommentar
hier unter das video und dann stellen
wir uns gerne wieder bei null grad auf
die straße und erklären euch das und
wenn ihr mehr lernen möchte zu diesem
thema dann empfehle ich euch ein
mitglied zu werden von easy german denn
als mitglied erhaltet ihr zu jedem video
auch zu diesem video interaktive
arbeitsblätter und wenn ihr lust habt
diese deutschen artikel mal ganz
systematisch zu lernen und auch
spielerisch zu lernen
dann schaut euch doch mal den gender
teil
unsere app sieht lang an danke fürs zu
sehen und bis bald
[Musik]